alors quand je donne un cours
d'intelligence artificielle ou quand je
donne une conférence grand public comme
comme celle qui est ici en général la
question ultime est toujours la même la
question ultime c'est donc ça
cristallise toujours pas mal de tensions
entre les gens qui sont pour et les gens
qui sont contre et donc finalement comme
je disais la question ultime et la
machine va t'elle un jour nous remplacer
et si oui quand est ce qu'elle va nous
remplacer alors si vous en êtes là
aujourd'hui
réveillez-vous réveillez-vous vraiment
parce que la machine a déjà commencé à
nous remplacer et ça fait belle lurette
que la machine a commencé à nous
remplacer
est ce que vous êtes capable de donner
une date de naissance à cet événement
depuis quand la machine a commencé à
nous remplacer alors moi je dirais 10
831 voilà c'est la date que je prendrais
comme référence 1831 c'est la date de la
première révolte des canuts à lyon
à l'époque c'est casimir perrier
président du conseil et qui va envoyer
la garde républicaine ou en d'autres
termes qui vont envoyer l'armée à lyon à
la croix-rousse plus précisément pour
mater la rébellion des canuts qui lutte
pour la défense de leurs emplois qui est
un petit peu à la fois pris par les
machines
la machine qui est concernée à cette
époque là c'est le métier à tisser
jacquard l'un des premiers l'une des
premières machines programmables alors
pour répondre à cette question la
machine va-t-elle nous remplacer ben il
faut quelque part s'interroger sur le
propre de l'homme alors qu'est ce que
c'est qu'un homme
on peut essayer de trouver quelques
quelques points d'accrochage pour
définir ce que c'est qu'un homme on sera
à peu près tous d'accord pour dire que
c'est quelqu'un d'une part qui est qui a
son libre arbitre qui a une certaine
autonomie c'est quelqu'un qui est
capable de s'adapter à son environnement
et qui a pas capables d'apprendre un
certain nombre de choses c'est quelqu'un
certainement qui est capable de se
reproduire parce que sinon on serait pas
tout cela et puis c'est quelqu'un qui
est capable d'avoir un certain nombre de
raisonnement qui sont qui sont plus ou
moins sophistiquées et bien à travers
c'est quatre points
je vais vous montrer que ça n'est pas
demain que la machine va avoir ses
différentes caractéristiques mais
qu'elle les a déjà et je vais vous
montrer point par point
que au bout du compte eh ben il n'y a
pas véritablement de différence de
nature entre l'homme et la machine
alors le premier point que je vais
prendre en exemple et quand on sort
d'une manière très fréquente dans les
différentes conférences c'est dans le
fond la machine fait uniquement ce que
l'homme lui dit de faire en ce sens la
machine est un esclave et c'est l'homme
qui la commande est donc au bout du
compte et bats la machine n'arrivera
jamais à faire mieux que l'homme puisque
c'est l'homme qui l'a programmée alors
cette idée là allait elle et elle date
déjà d'il ya longtemps elle a été
présentée par alan turing alan turing
c'est le père de l'informatique en 1950
dans un article dans un fameux article
qui s'appelle qui s'intitule les
machines peuvent ils penser et à cette
époque
alan turing présente cette objection
qu'on lui qu'on lui fait régulièrement
ils appellent ça le l'objection de lady
love laisse les guildes blesse c'est la
première phase la première femme
programmeuse de l'histoire de
l'informatique
alors il ya évidemment des tas de
problèmes mathématiques que l'on est
capable de coder dans la machine est
néanmoins on ne les maîtrisent pas
forcément c'est à dire que croire qu on
est capable que dès qu'on dit quelque
chose à la machine c'est qu'on le
maîtrise c'est une grave erreur
il ya plein de choses que l'on est
capable de décrire au niveau de la
machine et qui vont créer des processus
complexes que l'on ne maîtrise pas
forcément quand john conway par exemple
en 1970 s'invente son célèbre modèle du
jeu de la vie pour lui c'est une
récréation mathématiques ils imaginent
absolument pas les découvertes que vont
là pour que l'on veut que l'on va
pouvoir faire avec son modèle une
dizaine ou une vingtaine d'années après
il imagine pas les retombées théorique
extraordinaire qui va y'avoir suite à sa
découverte alors si j'avais un exemple à
vous donner
j'essaierai de vous donner l'exemple le
plus simple qui soit l'exemple le plus
simple et le plus extraordinaire qui
soit il est dû à un chercheur américain
qui s'appelle christopher langton qui en
1986 va présenter un modèle qu'un enfant
de 10 ans pourrait programmer qu'on
appelle maintenant la fourmi de l'anc
tonnes alors la fourmi de l'anc tonnes
c'est très simple c'est une c'est une
métaphore d'une petite fourmi un petit
automates qui fonctionne sur 1 sur 1
un échiquier géant sur un damier infini
avec un certain nombre de cases donc la
petite fourmi et sur une case et à la
capacité d'allumer ou d'éteindre cette
case elle peut la rendre blanche où elle
peut la rendre noir alors on pourrait se
lever tous
et puis regardez le carrelage qui est là
au sol et puis effectuer exactement les
mêmes actions que la petite fourmi a là
deux modes de comportement de règles de
comportement qui sont absolument trivial
la première c'est que si elle est sur
une case blanche à la noire si elle
tourne d'un quart de tour vers la droite
et elle avance à la casse d'à côté et si
par contre aller sur une case noire elle
l'a blanchi elle tourne à gauche elle
avance sur la case qui est à sa gauche
voilà donc à partir de ces deux règles
de base
eh bien vous voyez la fourmi qui va
commencer à développer son comportement
a marqué des cases à éteindre des cases
alors je vous le fais je vous fais le
début si toutes les cases sont blanches
et bien la fourmi ailée sur une case
blanche par définition à la noire si et
elle passe sur la case de droite qui est
blanche la noire si elle passe sur la
case de droite qui est blanche la noire
si elle passe sur la cage de droite qui
est blanche la noire si elle passe sur
une case qui est cette fois-ci noir à la
blanchi elle passe sur la passe de
gauche
alors vous voyez qu'un petit peu à la
fois la fourmi elle crée des formes qui
sont assez élégante qui sont assez
symétrique ce qu'elle fait en haut à
gauche c'est exactement la même chose
que ce qu'elle fait en bas à droite on a
l'impression que tout ça va continuer
tout le temps puis tout d'un coup elle
est prise de folie voilà tout d'un coup
elle fait n'importe quoi
elle part dans tous les sens et même
pire que ça au bout de plaies après dix
mille étape la fourmi elle en a marre la
fourmi elle se tire la fourmi elle part
elle part elle va créer ce qu'on appelle
une autoroute voilà donc une structure
qui est parfaitement rectiligne et qui
continue comme ça à l'infini alors
pourquoi la firme pourquoi la fourmi
s'en va eh bien on ne sait pas qu'est ce
qui se passe si vous avez mis plusieurs
fourmies en même temps on ne sait pas
vraiment l'expliquer non plus qu est ce
qui se passe si vous changez
l'environnement au départ en mettant des
cases noires et des cases blanches pas
on ne sait pas non plus tout ce qu'on
sait au bout du compte c'est le résultat
des quelques expériences qu'on a pu
faire
grosso modo on sait que de toute façon
quel que soit le nombre de fourmies et
quelles que soient les différents
environnements que vous avez est bien là
vous allez toujours avoir à peu près la
même trajectoire qui va ce qui va se
créer mais vous
et considérer que dire quelque chose à
la machine c'est le maîtriser eh ben
c'est beaucoup plus compliqué que ça
voilà on met en place des processus dans
la machine qu'on ne maîtrise pas
forcément alors le deuxième argument qui
est très souvent utilisée qui consiste à
dire que la différence qu'il ya entre
l'homme et la machine c'est que l'homme
sait s'adapter alors que la machine dans
le fond elle est pas tellement capable
de s'adapter alors la question de
l'adaptation à la question de
l'apprentissage évidemment et est
évidemment très importantes alors vous
le savez pour l'apprentissage on est
capable de faire plein de choses
aujourd'hui on est capable d'envoyer des
robots sur mars
les robots sont capables de faire la
cartographie de l'environnement ils sont
capables de passer un petit peu partout
des découvrir des endroits qu'ils
n'avaient pas découvert ils sont
capables de trier les roches ils sont
même pas capables ils sont même capables
de communiquer les uns avec les autres
les différentes informations qu'ils ont
pu avoir
il n'empêche évidemment que un moment
donné quand ils arrivent au bout de la
falaise et ben ils sont un petit peu
coincés ils sont pas capables de
s'adapter à cette nouvelle situation
mais l'homme non plus je veux dire
l'homme il n'est pas plus capable de
s'adapter à de nouvelles situations que
la machine
si vous pensez que l'homme est capable
de s'adapter à une nouvelle situation
vous prenez votre voisin vous le plonger
dans l'eau pendant dix minutes et vous
regardez ce qu'il en sort une fois que
vous le relever je veux dire l'homme il
n'est pas capable de s'adapter à des
situations qui sont dangereuses et
évidemment la capacité d'adaptation de
l'homme c'est exactement comme la
capacité d'adaptation de la machine ça
reste dans un cadre qui est très limité
l'homme il est capable de s'adapter dans
le cadre de son modèle génétique de la
même manière que la machine est capable
de s'adapter dans le cadre des systèmes
qui le peu qui lui permettent de
fonctionner si vous voulez le meilleur
exemple que l'on puisse donner dans
cette histoire là c'est l'histoire des
mondes virtuels voilà l'histoire des
mondes virtuels des mondes artificielle
comme ceux par exemple qu'on peut
trouver dans les jeux vidéo si vous
prenez les sims ou simcity simcity effet
actuellement avec un système ce qu'on
appelle un système multi agents avec des
agents artificielle qui sont à auto
adaptatif sont des agents qui sont
capables de regarder les différentes
entreprises qui a dans le monde virtuel
qui sont capables de trouver une
entreprise qui leur convient qu'ils vont
aller travailler pendant des années des
années dans cette entreprise jusqu'à
trousses de tout d'un coup
l'environnement dynamique ne change et
fasse apparaître une nouvelle entreprise
qui a
des caractéristiques qui sont sans doute
plus intéressantes et à ce moment là ils
vont changer de boulot ils vont aller
ailleurs exactement comme vous le feriez
l'apprentissage de la machine et
l'adaptation de la machine
eh bien vous l'homme est capable de le
faire dans une certaine mesure la
machine est capable de le faire aussi
dans le cadre qu'il a définie alors le
troisième point est très intéressant
troisième point revient tout le temps
aussi de manière récurrente ça consiste
à dire ça y est mais en fait moi j'ai
trouvé la différence fondamentale entre
l'homme et la machine
c'est que c'est l'homme qui fait la
machine bien sûr l'homme fait la machine
est pâle inverse
voilà est-ce que du coup est ce que la
machine est capable de se reproduire
voilà ça c'est une question qui est
intéressante alors le l'exemple plus le
plus concret que vous connaissez c'est
le virus vous avez déjà été confronté à
des virus informatiques vous savez ce
que sont les virus informatiques
un virus informatique il a besoin de
deux choses pour fonctionner il a besoin
d'une adaptative it et ceux dont on
vient de parler précédemment et il a dû
besoin d'une capacité de reproduction
mais les virus sont capables de
coloniser des ensembles de machines
les virus sont même capables de se
reproduire à un tel point qu'ils sont
capables de coloniser toutes les
machines de la planète qui sont même
capable de muter pour qu'on les
reconnaisse pas le virus c'est l'exemple
même de la machine auto reproductrices
alors le problème de l'auto reproduction
des machines ça date pas non plus d'hier
l'auto reproduction des machines c'est
une question qui est posée par john von
neumann le père d architecture d
ordinateurs en 1940 en 1946 pose la
question de l'automate aux reproducteurs
alors il va trouver une solution qui est
assez compliquée à l'époque et qui va
être affiné un petit peu à la fois au
fur et à mesure du temps et en 1986
christopher langton dont on a parlé déjà
là précédemment va proposer un modèle
qui est beaucoup plus simple que celui
de vote de man mais qui illustre
exactement le même phénomène et qu'on
appelle aujourd'hui la boucle de l'anc
tonnes alors la boucle de l'anc tonnes
c'est un dispositif qui est très simple
vous avez une machine qui représentait
parce que vous voyez là une sorte
cellule quelque part qui contient en son
sein son propre code adn d'auto
reproduction donc vous avez une membrane
cellulaire en rouge
et puis vous avez à l'intérieur des
gènes
qui effectue un certain nombre d'actions
donc vous avez par exemple le gène qui
fait pousser la membrane cellulaire vous
avez le gène qui la fait tourner sur
elle-même et c est quand la membrane
cellulaire re boucle sur elle-même et
bien on se retrouve avec ce qu'on
appelle une division cellulaire et vous
vous retrouvez avec deux cellules qui
ont exactement le même code adn d'auto
reproduction donc au départ vous partez
avec une cellule après vous en avez 2
après vous en avez 4 après il y en avait
huit après vous en avait 16
alors si vous voulez représenter ça dans
un espace d'odessa fini à un moment
donné par par poser un petit problème
donc on rajoute à un petit gène on
rajoute un jeune castrateur le jeune
castrateur fait en sorte qu'une fois que
la machine a été reproduite quatre fois
à l'arrêt de sa reproduction
ce que vous voyez ici au niveau des
cellules centrales les saluts centrale
ne bouge plus il n'y a plus que les
cellules qui sont tout autour qui
continue de de s'auto reproduire alors
les virus les automates aux
reproducteurs et bien c'est autant
d'exemples qui voit qui doit vous donner
à réfléchir sur la reproductibilité des
machines alors le dernier point qui est
souvent évoquée consiste à dire que la
différence qu'il ya entre l'homme et la
machine est bien c'est que dans le fond
la machine à l'utilisent la force brute
alors que l'homme résonne c'est toujours
marrant d'entendre ça parce que l'homme
on lui donne tout le temps des capacités
extraordinaires l'homme résonne qu'est
ce que ça veut dire que l'homme
raisonnée qu'est ce que ça veut dire que
la machine utilise la force brute
j'ai pas trop ce que ça veut dire
utiliser la force brute dans la tête des
gens au bout du compte j'imagine quelque
part que ce qui se dit c'est que on va
développer tous les coups possibles et
peut-être que en ayant développé tous
les coups possibles on va voir lequel
est le bon
si vous prenez le cas du jeu d'échecs si
vous développez tous les coups possibles
au jeu d'échecs il va vous falloir des
dizaines d'années des centaines d'années
voire des milliers d'années pour finir
ne serait ce qu'une partie
il ya un nombre incalculable de coups
pour un nombre incalculable de partis
auquel vous pouvez obtenir voilà c'est
un espace gigantesque à parcourir si la
machine à l'utiliser simplement la force
brute pour calculer tous les coups mais
jamais dit blues auraient battu kasparov
en 1996
je vous le rappelle la machine est
championne du monde d'échecs depuis 20
ans déjà alors la machine deep blue qui
a battu kasparov à l'utiliser
pas simplement de la force brute la
machine cible où elle fait du
raisonnement par analogie à la des
bibliothèques d'ouverture la
bibliothèque de fermeture elle compare
avec dans ce cas une partie
alphée du raisonnement hypothétique elle
se demande si si elle joue tel truc et
ben salah l'adversaire va mieux réagir
que si elle joue tel autre chose à
l'utilisent des heuristiques elle fait
des choix basé sur deux est rustique
sans être vraiment sûr qu'elle fait les
bons choix
bref elle résonne elle résonne
exactement comme l'homme résonne vous ne
pouvez pas dire que la machine utilise
la force brute simplement pour avoir
réussi à être championne du monde
aux échecs ou pourra être championne du
monde au go ou comme cette année la
machine devient championne du monde aux
jeux de poker la machine ne le fait pas
avec la force brute la machine
évidemment le fait avec du raisonnement
alors au bout du compte on en arrive à
donc à cette question qui est rituel qui
est la machine va-t-elle nous remplaçait
alors je voulais dire c'est celle ce
processus a débuté en 1831 avec avec la
révolte des canuts et la machine la
machine à tisser jakaré depuis bas la
machine grignote des parts de marché un
petit peu à la fois alors c'est terminé
maintenant il n'y a plus d'opérateurs
téléphoniques
aujourd'hui il n'y a plus de point son
honneur aux lilas il n'y a plus il n'y a
plus
des tas de métiers qui ont disparu et
est par contre chez vous et bien vous
avez des outils basés sur l'intelligence
artificielle un petit peu partout vous
avez tous maintenant une machine à laver
qui pèsent le linge avant de laver elle
pèse le là j'avais essaye de calculer la
quantité optimale d'eau et d'électricité
qu'il faudrait avoir pour pour nettoyer
le linge c'est autre chose que l'ancien
lavandières si vous voulez alors bien
évidemment la machine allait forte en
tout point alors loin de moi l'idée de
vous dire que la machine s'est ouvert la
machine ne sait pas tout faire c'est ça
qui est extraordinaire c'est qu'on a mis
une limite à l'intelligence de la
machine on est capable de fixer la
limite de l'intelligence de la machine
ce qu'on appelle des indécidable il ya
des problèmes dont on sait que la
machine ne sera jamais résoudre
quelle qu'elle soit la machine
d'aujourd'hui la machine de demain avec
le langage d'aujourd'hui est que l'on
d'âge de demain en doublant sa puissance
de calcul sa capacité mémoire il ya des
problèmes que la machine ne sera jamais
résoudre le plus simple des dites d
indécidable s'est demandé à une machine
en lui donnant un programme si ce
programme là va s'arrêter ou pas dans la
machine elle sait pas le faire et elle
ne saura jamais le faire voilà ce qu'on
appelle l'indécidabilité dollar et la
machine ne sait pas le faire
mais l'homme ne sait pas le faire non
plus c'est pas plus facile pour un homme
de savoir si un programme va s'arrêter
ou pas la machine comme l'homme se
retrouve face à ceux à ce problème
exactement au même niveau
alors finalement quelle est la
différence de nature entre l'homme et la
machine dans la vue
la machine allait capable d'un certain
libre arbitre un de temps en temps la
fourmi elle fait un truc qu'on
n'imaginait pas vraiment ce que ce
qu'allait faire de la machine elle est
capable d'adaptation la machine elle est
capable de se reproduire la cab la
machine elle est capable de faire des
mécanismes de raisonnement de haut
niveau ben fondamentalement il n'y a pas
véritablement différence de nature entre
l'homme et la machine
voilà les deux sons sont globalement
semblables alors maintenant on peut
quand même atténué un petit peu ce
propos un puisque même si la machine en
tout point bas l'homme dans toutes les
catégories
la machine aujourd'hui elle est
meilleure que l'homme pour détecter les
cellules cancéreuses a les meilleurs
colom pour jouer aux échecs elle est
meilleure que l'homme pour jouer au
poker a les meilleurs colom à peu près
partout mais attention c'est pas la même
machine
y'a pas
unia il ya des ziya il ya des machines
il ya des outils ya des algorithmes il
ya des technologies l'homme y les moyens
dans tous les domaines face à la machine
mais aujourd'hui il a encore un avantage
c'est qu'il sait les faire à peu près
tous la machine allait beaucoup plus
sectorisé qu l'homme c'est tout son
problème
alors on pourrait rêver à une
intelligence générale 1 aujourd'hui la
science aller assez partagés sur la
création d'une certaine intelligence
générale qui serait capable de résoudre
tous les problèmes
si vous me posez la question à moi moi
personnellement j'y crois en tout cas je
vois aucune impossibilité à avoir une
machine qui serait suffisamment général
pour qu'elles traitent tous les
problèmes auxquels on la confronte et
qu'elle soit à peu près l'équivalent de
l'homme mais ce qui est sûr c'est que
c'est le chemin va être très long va
être très difficile et que c'est
certainement pas pour demain voilà ce
qui ont l'audace de croire que c'est
impossible se trompent et ceux qui ont
l'audace de croire que c'est pour demain
se trompe aussi merci
[Applaudissements]